c'est une mer de déchets que vous voyez
derrière moi plusieurs tonnes de
détritus divers se sont amoncelées
crescendo depuis dix ans sur cette
plaine maraîchère pneus gravats de
chantier issus du bâtiment pièces
détachées chaussures oursons la nature
de ces déchets est diverse et représente
38 mille tonnes vous avez vu la carte
tout à l'heure on voit que nous avons
des bouts de décharge un petit peu
disséminés sur un ensemble de
territoires énorme et qui aujourd'hui
pose de vraies difficultés à la fois
bien évidemment de dépollution et de
nettoyage mais également en amont
comment faire pour que ce type de chose
ne se reproduise plus du tout sur nos
territoires
présente partout sur le territoire les
décharges sauvages sont un véritable
fléau qui coûte entre 340 et 420
millions d'euros par an aux
collectivités brune poirson secrétaire
d'état auprès de la ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire est
venu apporter ses solutions la lutte
contre les décharges sauvages est un des
piliers du projet de loi anti gaspillage
pour une économie circulaire c'est la
reprise gratuite des déchets qui auront
été triés au préalable
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous savez
beaucoup d'artisans par exemple ils
doivent s'ils veulent aller déposer
leurs déchets dans une déchetterie
doivent payer pour ça donc ce qu'on a à
faire c'est que ce soit gratuit donc
pour eux ce soit facile plus facile d'y
aller on veut que la filière pollueur
payeur finance la mise en place d'un
maillage très dense de déchèteries
professionnelles partout en france
d'autre part nous allons créer un régime
spécial de sanctions sur pour permettre
données pour permettre de donner au
maire ceux qui sont au contact
malheureusement et on l'a vu avec le
drame du décès du maire de signes cet
été pour ceux qui s'opposent eux qui
sont en première ligne et les moyens
véritablement de s'attaquer
immédiatement à ceux qui commettent ces
actes illégaux et insupportable pendant
ce déplacement des associations sont
venus faire part de leur inquiétude
parmi elles l'association rives de seine
nature environnement on nous indique que
la législation va évoluer très bien si
elle se durcit mais il faut aussi que
les tribunaux appliquent les
réglementations aujourd'hui je rappelle
quand même une entreprise qui déversent
des déchets sur un site comme suit car
cette fois-ci s'expose à 75 millions
demande deux ans de prison et la saisie
du véhicule fait le tour de tous les
tribunaux de france et vous verrez que
cette ascension n'a jamais été appliquée
huit cent mille euros c'est le montant
que l'état versera pour ce nettoyage
d'un coût total de 3 millions d'euros